so far we have noticed that with this
guy
with this particular expansion right
the greatest coefficient the the biggest
number
the biggest one of these there's either
one or two of them
right but wherever the one or two are
they are always where are they
positioned
they're right in the middle aren't they
and we did this with pascal's triangle
right for example i think the row we
looked at a lot was uh
one five ten ten five one
so you can see in this case if n were
equal to five
there are our two greatest coefficients
you either get that one
or every alternating row
you'll just get one right in the middle
you get the idea but it's in the middle
that's the important thing
okay now here's the thing though this
breaks down
in any other case apart from this right
if you don't just have one
and x if you've got something else
okay um because of the different
shape of this expansion the greatest
coefficient is not always nearly in the
middle let's rehearse this okay
this is the simple case it's an easy one
right
what are you going to get as the
expansion for this binomial term
okay you're still going to start with n0
but then what do you have
attached to the front there will be a
there will be and lots of them right
how many b's will there be none okay so
i could write i could write b
now as i move along i'm going to get the
next coefficient
i'll have one less a and one more b
we've seen this before
right one less one more one less one
more until all the way at the
end right you've got your n choose n
you've got no lots of a left and then
you've got all of your b's
which in this case is x right so based
on what a and b
are right it's going to tilt the top or
tilt the greatest coefficient
one way or another let me give you some
examples
okay we'll start with a simple one we'll
go with say
let me just think let's do it cubed i
want to make it too hard for us
okay we'll do the standard case which is
symmetrical
like this okay by now i think we should
be able to rattle this off right
what are the coefficients you're going
to start with
one how many x's three
how many x squares three again
and then you get your x cubed term okay
now if i take the second term here right
in the binomial and i double it
right you need some space you should
leave some space in here as well by the
way
so double spacing if i make that 2x
what will happen to the coefficients
okay well
the first one will still be one okay but
here
i'm gonna get three lots of
2x so this will be six x right
next one over are three lots of three
lots of what
2x all squared so that's three lots of
4x squared
that's 12x squared yes okay
what did my last term be it'll be it'll
be
2x all cubed which is 8x cubed
okay okay so you can see
i've sort of moved over number one i
don't have two that are the same
number two it's leaning over this side
which reflects this number here
if i change the number if i make it
bigger i'll choose an easy example
let's go and make it say 10 times bigger
okay
it becomes a little more pronounced
right i've chosen an easy number so
let's see if we can do it
it still starts with one move over what
do you get
3 lots of 10x
right
now we'll get 3 lots of
100x so 300
x squared right what's my final term
it'll be a thousand right x cubed
okay so you can see i've i've leaned all
the way this way
okay rather than sort of a nice
symmetrical sort of shape
like that right and this one which is
sort of leaning over a little bit
this one's just leaned over all the way
right in terms of my coefficients they
just keep on getting bigger and bigger
and bigger
and you can probably imagine if i change
instead of this number
if i change this number it would lean
the other way
right if my first number was say 10 if i
did 10 plus x all cubed
then these coefficients would be exactly
backwards
does that make sense so far in fact
let's actually just for the sake of it
let's just put that example down
okay what are we going to get it'll be
the same as this but 1000 here
300 here 30
and then one letter execute
now what i'm interested in doing is
trying to get a general approach toward
finding
well which one is the biggest one in
these examples because they've only each
got four terms i can just do them and
the numbers are nice and easy so
no problem just write them all out okay
but if these powers are high and if
these terms in here are awkward
right it becomes increasingly difficult
to just write them all out
we want a more sophisticated efficient
method of doing this okay
now just to provide one more sort of
justification for why we're doing this
uh we're in binomial theorem right now
right um after the trials one of the
most important topic is probability
okay the hardest part of probability is
binomial probability
okay it's directly feeding out of this
now you're like
what does this have to do with
probability
binomial probability means the
probability of two things
when you've got two choices for example
heads and tails
right or if you're rolling a dice maybe
evens and odds
okay everywhere you got two choices
these two things in here the one in the
x or the a and the b
if they were probabilities
if there were probabilities and i did
this over and over again for example if
i did an experiment and what was the
number i gave you like 11 or something
like that
if i did something like this to the
power of 11
okay eventually when i get this
expansion out
all these things over here
they will be the probabilities of
different strings of events
okay so actually finding out which one
of these is the biggest
is kind of a useful thing it tells you
what is the most likely thing to happen
that's what a bigger probability means
doesn't it
okay so even at the moment it's kind of
abstract and kind of who cares what the
greatest coefficient is where does it go
right
well in a month and a bit it goes here
okay so we have to build this and be
able to be quite confident